In part two of our interview with the author of the Immaculate Constellation report.
So the idea that it could have been a war game, could it have been something, you know, some of these UFOs that have been seen over nuclear missile bases, silos and things of that sort.
The implication has been, as with drones, that it's a readiness test of some sort.
If that had been the only thing I had seen and none of the rest of this saga had happened, we wouldn't be talking.
And I go and I have a meeting with Sissy, give them the paper, including the various compartments and programs that they could themselves look into to access the same information that I saw, which is ridiculous that Congress has no access to.
So when I was in USDI, I read the transcripts of Sean Patrick briefing Senator Rubio, Senator Warren and Senator Gillibrand on the results of his investigation in his congressionally tasked investigation.
In those transcripts, which were supposed to be open kimono, here's the truth, Mr. Senator, Mr. Senator, Sean Kirkpatrick absolutely distorted.
Saying what? What did he say that was a lie?
You know, I read these transcripts once and immediately knew that...
Veiled threat?
No, I knew that I was now something else.
I was in...
I had inside...
I had knowledge into the deception of our government by elements of our intelligence community.
People will be so curious.
So what comes on the fourth page?
Talks through the pages.
Just go ahead.
Yeah.
So, I mean, like I said, the second series, the second and third examples were less interesting to me.
But, you know, they are images of orbs transiting from coastal facilities out to the ocean and sort of describing...
You know, what those facilities were as, I think, the unspoken implication of why something like this would be out there.
And, yes, just a similar or just a bit not vague, but a general description of we observed this coming from this direction or from where this facility, sensitive facility was left over the ocean.
You know, this was our task asset and it happened on this date.
Anything...
Really striking in the rest of that document that really highlighted to you.
Anything else in that document that was really striking?
Yeah.
So the last example of the four was back to Russia again.
This time, I believe, in the Atlantic Ocean.
And it shows another Russian intelligence vessel underway this time at night.
The image is green infrared.
And it shows above this Russian.
Vessel is another black triangle, but where is the first example in the Pacific was an equilateral, large, pretty stunning object that was of comparable size to the vessels below it.
This was a more definitely smaller, is smaller than the vessel, and it was more angular in shape and sort of swept back.
And it was also accompanied by text saying that there was no indication that the Russian vessel was responding in any way to this.
Ship hovering above it.
And it did not describe in this instance whether it had miraculously appeared or if it was tailing the ship.
But triangular in shape and hovering.
Well, hovering probably matching speed, though, too, with the ship.
Like USS Russell, other people argue, and I don't care what shape it is.
You know, when you have something with range finders off of a ship that goes with it, stops with the ship, continues.
So this is not a new thing, this idea of triangular by angle of observation pyramid.
It's not a new thing, this idea of triangular by angle of observation pyramid.
Some would say.
Could be.
Right.
So that's striking.
And you saw that, too.
Yes.
Yeah.
And that was the last example.
After that was sort of a summary slide or two about just recapping, like, the fact that these incidents are, we are collecting, sorry, we are collecting these incidents around the world.
That we are focused on UAPRB collection incidents by tasked and untasked assets and the collection and analysis of those data.
So sometimes we know where it's going to be, tasked assets.
Sometimes we just happen to capture them, untasked assets.
Correct.
And I think a good example is in that brief itself, where the orb incidents appeared to be untasked assets.
They were not there to collect on orbs.
They were there to collect on something else.
And they happened to catch something.
Whereas the two Russian incidents, we were there.
We were there to watch the Russians and their Russians' interactions with this technology.
Wow.
So your suspicions after seeing this 12-page.
Report is that these are freeze frames of what are.
Videos.
Yeah.
So somewhere there's a bigger collection of this stuff that's also very interesting.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Like, you know, there was informal collections of this stuff by interested people on those systems.
And there's absolutely a professional mission-tasked databases for this.
Okay.
So you've seen.
Now you have this.
You've seen a lot of exposure.
You try to do the right thing.
And you take great steps to try to do.
It takes a little while for you.
It does.
So explain that to me, what you tried to do.
So there you go.
You see something that you know shouldn't be there on that archive.
You know, what happens?
What do you do?
Absolutely nothing.
In fact, the first time I read that, I don't know what I just read and if it's even real.
Maybe somebody just made this thing.
Okay.
Explain that.
So you can.
It would be like a joke or something.
Or they put it.
They put it together literally for a war game, right?
They had maybe created an imaginary program that maybe they wanted to have, right?
Or a desired capability or something that was a representative of the true thing to be used.
Is that normal or common now?
That's a weird thought.
It is a weird thought, but this is what's going through my head because it's so bizarre.
Okay.
And.
You're like, no way.
Yeah.
I'm going through everything.
All the options.
Why it's not what it is.
Right.
Yeah.
And so I do nothing for some time.
And then we, uh, our office gets a training on like, or a refresh training, but this was
new in my career.
So my first time on what to do in cases of spillage for sap material.
Okay.
And I realized, well, no matter how weird this is, this has all the hallmarks of what
you guys just said is a big fucking deal.
So, you know, I can either pretend like I didn't open and read this.
This thing 80 times and hope that, uh, it doesn't notice that either, or I can report it myself.
Uh, so I did that, or I tried to do that.
You tried to report it.
You read it a bunch as it's fascinating.
And then you, you try to report it.
So what does that look like when you try to report that?
What'd you do?
So the first time, uh, I, I went, uh, just quietly to, uh, my, I guess my immediate supervisor, a retired, uh, army colonel.
So you go to your, uh, supervisor, superior.
Mm-hmm.
What would.
I gotta say, Hey, I got a.
Show you something in, in our, in our closet.
Uh, our whole office is a skiff, but inside the skiff is another tiny skiff.
Um, and I think we, we have like a, a spillage things.
And so I need to show it to you, cuz this is apparently what we're supposed to do.
Show it to your boss.
Um, and then follow the reporting chain and you sign, you sign a paper and that's how it's supposed to be handled all by the books.
And they just trained you on it and you're like, okay, here's what I'm supposed to do.
Right, exactly.
So I've tried to follow that while also being, you know, quiet about it.
Um, take him in and he's like, okay, so, so show me what you found.
I pull up that slide and, uh, you know, the first, the first slide, you just, because it's so generic, it's no reaction, but then going to like the, maybe the second slide or, or even the third slide, he's just like, okay, stop.
Like, stop, did you read this?
And I don't answer, but I just look him in the eye and I look at the screen and I'm like, of course, this, that's how you know it exists.
And he definitely picked up on that.
And he, uh, the conversation ended with him saying, uh, delete it.
And he left the room.
Yeah.
And we never spoke of it again.
He's cutting you some slack there in essence, without me knowing.
Yes.
Yeah.
You didn't read it.
Uh, so you're not in any trouble that's here.
Delete it.
And also, as I came to learn, um, you know, it, certain material, uh, you get exposed to, and it's, you're kind of marked for life that that happened.
And, uh, it's probably not good for your career at a minimum.
We've seen other whistleblower friends of ours have, uh, experiences like that.
They're marked.
Yeah.
Didn't realize that at the time.
Um, so that happened, uh, I sit on that for a few days, didn't sit right with me cause I'm still thinking like, well, that's not what we're supposed to do.
I could do that, but everything, supposedly everything we do on those systems, every click, every keystroke is monitored.
So like, I just, I need to self-preservation.
I need to do the, keep doing the right thing here.
So I go to his boss or his boss's boss.
I, I changed my approach.
I don't say what it is.
I don't show it to them.
Um, I don't print it out.
And I just say, uh, ma'am, uh, we have a, a spillage incident.
I believe it's SAP material.
Um, could you please provide guidance on, on how to handle this?
And so, uh, through that, uh, I was connected to, uh, our parent offices, uh, special access, special access program control officer, um, had a meeting set up to go meet with them a few days later that happened.
I go to that meeting, uh, uh, in a.
SAP F, uh, so where this material is supposed to be stored and handled.
And this person says, okay, show me the material.
So, uh, I sit down.
Round two.
Right.
Exactly.
Well, you're showing the material.
I sit down, I pull it up.
It's like, it's right there at the top of the shared servers though.
I'm not like it's, it's almost instant.
Like it's right there.
Uh, I pull it up.
I start scrolling through it from the bottom.
I get no reaction.
Then he says, okay, let me look at it.
He takes my chair.
He goes through, he scrolls through it.
No reaction on his face.
I'm.
Watching him very closely at this point.
Cause I'm exceptionally curious about all of this.
No reaction.
Uh, then he scrolls through it again and he makes a very deliberate, uh, scene
where he pauses on Lou Elizondo's slide and starts guffawing in a very, uh,
non-believable way and saying, somebody's having a joke, uh, this, uh, you
don't need to worry about this.
You can go.
And that's not the reaction I was expecting, I was expecting to at the
very least sign the paper.
Right.
Saying, you know, this incident happened, reported it, signed it, you know, it's done.
Uh, so, you know, I, I try to ask him, like, are you, are you sure?
Like, do I need to sign anything?
He's like, nope, you can go.
And so I left that room and, uh, never, ever had anything about that incident come up again.
Except immediately you went and checked again for the file.
Yeah.
I went upstairs and I went to see what had happened and it was gone.
So the idea that it could have.
Been a war game.
Could it have been something, you know, some of these UFOs that had been seen over
nuclear missile bases, silos, and things of that sort there, the implication has
been as with drones, that it's a readiness test of some sort, we're going to put some
secret, uh, operation unexpected, uh, and see how people and systems react to it.
Could that have been what was going on here?
Yeah.
I mean, it is something that, you know, on the surface level appears plausible.
I just, I do not believe that.
I mean, I don't think it would be the case given the circumstances of how it was located.
The fact that hundreds of people had access to that system, the fact of it's generic labeling.
It wasn't, you know, there was no red flags on that to draw, uh, draw any, uh, draw any
fish to the bait as it were, um, to catch somebody.
And then the process of, of reporting it, you know, there, there's no outcome from that.
Uh, besides apparently making a lot of people pissed off and worried and kind of scared.
Um, so something that we noticed, and I believe it's true reporting, which is that when David
Gresh testified, um, Immaculate Constellation before the world ever knew those words was
searched on Google a ton.
Additionally, over the research and time and sources that we have, um, you know, it has
been confirmed to us under no uncertain terms that that was the name of a program with that
nature.
So if we're looking at it as like a LARP, LARP kind of thing, we get to the point where there's
too many outsides.
There's too many outside confirmation after the fact as well as that.
Yeah.
If that would have been the only thing I had seen and none of the rest of this saga had
happened, we wouldn't be talking.
Totally.
You, you wrote, um, in a paper that was submitted to Congress and we'll go to a lot of, uh,
details in that, but that this was deeply disturbing overall.
Why was it disturbing to you?
Yeah.
So it, as time passed, it became disturbing, um, especially, uh,
after the sort of, um, the process of Grush coming forward, left a wake on the inside
too, uh, people were tracking that weren't even involved, but we're able to see sort of
the distortions on the inside, um, distortions of truth, exactly.
And, but also, you know, bureaucracies and offices behaving weirdly, um, uh, around this
subject and sort of the movements for reaching out to Congress, uh, to get legislation drafted,
uh, that.
It eventually became that intelligence authorization act and that first NDAA, uh, where they provided
whistleblower protections.
Um, I think that, that was one of the moments that really, uh, started to convince me that this
was, this was not, um, under, under our, our government's control.
That's our core of why we're talking today.
Yes.
What do you mean?
Um, just on an emotional level, uh, and blunt analysis.
Why the hell is Congress passing a law asking for UFO, uh, insiders from the intelligence
and military, military community to come talk to them directly under amnesty about something
that doesn't exist, isn't an issue.
Um, and if it is, does exist and is an issue, but it's secret, uh, apparently our most sensitive
congressional committees are not briefed on this.
Yeah.
I find it at the core disturbing you having, uh, Arrow even asked for whistleblowers to
come forward to them.
Um, uh, having Congress asking for whistleblowers to come under amnesty to come to them.
Yeah.
Something's rotten with that.
And then also at the same time, seeing the, the, the sort of UAP task force and its slow
death, uh, on the inside and the death of the, you know, sort of open exchange of ideas
and problem solving going on as another data point that pointed to something rotten.
And, uh, the last one that really sealed it, uh, and really convinced me.
That I need to find a way to, uh, bring this to Congress, no matter, no matter how small
it might be, it apparently matters, uh, was, uh, when I was in USDI, I read the transcripts
of Sean Patrick, uh, briefing Senator Rubio, Senator Warren and Senator Gillibrand on the
results of his investigation in his congressionally tasked, uh, Arrow report and those transcripts,
which were supposed to be a open kimono.
Uh, here's the truth, Mr.
Senator.
Mr. Senator, uh, Sean Kirkpatrick absolutely distorted downplayed and can't prove it, but
I would say outright lied to, to the people who have direct responsibility for him saying
what, what would, what did he say?
That was a lot.
So it's more of a lie of the whole thing, the big picture, right?
In the meeting, it's, you know, oh, we, you know, Congressman Rubio, you know, we've,
we've heard about this incident.
Uh, we just don't have enough data to go on it.
We don't really know what this is.
Uh, we don't have any way of really, uh, figuring out what's going on.
Um, it could just be an anomaly.
In fact, it's most likely anomaly.
So starting with an acknowledgement that, you know, here you, oh yeah, you have some data,
but we have the insight and the scientific expertise to, to make you feel at ease.
Nothing to see here, folks.
Exactly.
Although there was also political discussion involved in historic discussion.
Um, and you know, I read these transcripts once, uh, and.
Immediately knew that, uh, yeah.
Veiled threat.
No, I, I knew that I was now something else.
I was in, I had inside knowledge into the deception of our government by elements of
our intelligence community.
Um, my blood ran cold of specific point in that transcript where Mr.
Rubio is discussing, uh, the legacy program.
This was a subject of direct discussion with Sean Kirkpatrick in these meetings.
And based on Mr.
Kirkpatrick's replies about, uh, as vague as they were, uh, but unable to escape the truth of the legacy program, Mr.
Rubio's response was, well, what the hell is the executive branch doing?
Have they been running this for 60 years without congressional oversight?
I might be paraphrasing a little, but that's near enough verbatim.
And I saw that line and I, I basically closed that file and, uh, had a pretty sleepless night.
All right.
Uh, you said your blood ran cold.
Meaning you're pissed, you're spooked, scared, scared, scared for your country.
I just think in general, it's like a, I don't know, there was nothing associated.
It was just like immediate.
Oh, fuck.
Good response.
Yeah.
I mean, you now know this is real.
This is a coverup.
They are lying about this stuff.
Yeah.
At that point, I definitely knew the phenomenon was absolutely real.
I knew we were tracking it.
I knew we had, uh, lots of resources on it for some time, but getting to that final, like, uh, step in the way.
The ladder and seeing like, oh, and the coverup is real and it's inside the house.
Give us a sense of it.
You read one document that said immaculate constellation, and it had some images with it.
What additional information did you come across that reinforced your belief that there is a big surveillance program collecting this stuff?
Well, I mean, uh, one is just the fact of its existence, right?
In, in the brief, it's talking about the general mission.
It's given examples, but it's clearly talking about a collection mission.
And then there's, there's a.
Uh, programs that have since become public, uh, the most relevant one in this case is the NRO sentient program, uh, that kind of, at least in the open source way demonstrates how you don't need a massive workforce to do this anymore.
You don't need, uh, buildings without windows for acres to people taking this information and sanitizing it to making it sure it gets to the right people without the wrong things in it.
Uh, and that's just on the inside, right?
Like you don't.
Also need exposure to a bunch of human beings with individual egos and identities to be clear.
There there's kind of AI siphoning off of data and information to keep it compartmentalized without spine of human eyes, even within our intelligence agencies, if I'm understanding.
And yeah, it's a bit of a Janus, a two faced God.
It takes things in one end and make sure you hear what you need to hear out the other, right?
And you suspect that, uh, UAP when that data is collected and brought in and ingested that there is a, uh, whitewashing or not whitewashing of it.
There's a, a clarifying of that stuff to, to make sure the general people in the intelligence community don't see it.
Absolutely.
And that's a longstanding practice for, especially for imagery intelligence.
Uh, just, uh, nothing about UFOs, you know, back in the cold war days, if, if something, a facility or an aerospace platform was seen that, um, sorry, it was collected, uh, you know, there would be either there'd be a full version, right.
For those who needed it.
Uh, but if you just needed to see the facility, but maybe.
Not the plane, you know, those would be manually excised.
Now we have, uh, tools to do that for us.
Could you describe then for us, uh, how you think this works, whatever the name for it is now, how it works.
Did we have an AI system in 2018 that could do what we're describing?
Well, we know we did, um, those documents have since become public, right?
Sentient, sentient, right.
Um, and the fact that sentient was operational at those, uh, dates of the documents mean it was operational for years.
Before.
Before then, uh, years before 2018, you know, we've had our conversations private and otherwise about this kind of an operation.
And it just seems like, gosh, there should be somebody who's collecting all this information and studying it and trying to figure it out.
And the fact that it goes into the executive branch somewhere, if that's what happens to it.
Good.
I'm glad somebody is doing it.
Why is that?
As you've learned about it, why is that not necessarily a good idea?
Is it because it's not maybe really within the executive branch that it's, it's an entity.
Why it may not be a good idea to censor our intelligence products that are circulated within our cleared community, uh, to our service members that are on the front lines every day, uh, is because you are, uh, blinding them to their environment.
You are opening them to threats, you're exposing them to risks, and you are essentially inhibiting, uh, the pursuit of national security objectives by doing so.
There's a reason you guys have talked to so many whistleblowers from the military who see these things.
Uh, that's because, partially because they're reporting it, they feel endangered by it, uh, and nothing is being done and no answers are being given.
And they are in some cases suffering legitimate injuries.
These images that would pop up here and there on, on some system, on some platform, um, this AI program that was once called Immaculate Constellation, it would grab them, take them away, and then they're gone from those platforms, those places.
So like CIA or, or something.
I believe we're.
Where it could, it, you know, the data was ingested essentially in a, you know, a stovepipe, right?
It's, it's locked off, it goes in, it goes into the black box, and then a product comes out for what you're cleared to see and what you have a need to know to see.
Wouldn't somebody say, hey, where's my image that I recorded?
Uh, and then where'd it go?
Yeah, there's a lot of people who have had, uh, incidents like that.
There, you know, we also have to remember there's a lot of surveillance and reconnaissance, uh, platforms.
Not all of these are controlled by military or national intelligence.
And, uh, I believe a lot of, uh, what was, you know, circulated for some time among the community was people at combatant commands or with operational units.
Uh, they have their own platforms, essentially.
They control that data to a large degree, and they were able to decide that it goes on JWICs, not, uh, into the black box.
Right.
So I've heard this over and over and over that there are these, uh, pipelines of communication, let's say, overseas to CENTCOM.
But there's a squeezing.
Point, there's a narrowing point where stuff doesn't get where it's intended to get, and that that's been a problem operationally, especially when it comes to UAP stuff, people have tried to track and follow what they've submitted and it didn't get where it needed to.
It's been siphoned off.
To be clear, Immaculate Constellation is not, um, an AI scrubbing program, just, you know, so we, our audience understands that, um, we've described what Immaculate Constellation is, but that is an element we suspect from the literature and knowledge of what is public.
That there is that capability.
That there is that capability to scrub instead of, like, airbrushing out UFOs from NASA or something.
And, and part of the, uh, the way of knowing what this is, is knowing who in the DoD at least has, uh, you know, primary responsibility over SAPs.
Uh, OSD policy really only has control over operational SAPs and logistical SAPs.
Then you will have OSD research and engineering and acquisition sustainment.
They will have, uh, you know, your science and technology SAPs.
That'll that.
They are the people who, who they're the gatekeepers for that world.
And then you'll have your intelligence or USDI in this case, uh, their SAPs and CAPs, and those are intelligence SAPs.
Uh, they are the primary keepers of that.
So the implication there is that, you know, if OSD policy is being briefed on that Immaculate Constellation is a parent SAP, not for a specific platform, but for a mission.
I think the core of this for me is.
At one point, Matt realized, holy shit, this is real.
This is a problem.
And people are being lied to people that, um, need to know the truth that it's being siphoned off, uh, outside of control of what should be our representative government.
And let me know if I'm saying anything that's wrong from your perspective, but I think there's a point that he hits like you and I have hit we're being fucking lied to, and it's becoming dangerous your first sentence in, in the report that we fought to get on congressional record.
We'll get into.
That we've fought for that together.
This document is a result of a multi-year internal investigation into the subject of unidentified anomalous phenomenon.
That first sentence in your report that we fought to get into congressional record for a reason.
So basically your blood goes cold.
You're like, oh fuck.
And then you do a multi-year internal investigation.
Explain that it's your first sentence.
What'd you do?
Um, at the time of that, uh,
knowledge, um, you know, I was still in the Pentagon, um, but I was not a whistleblower.
Uh, my investigation at that point was in the pursuit of my duties in countering WMD.
Um, also my professional curiosity.
You went deep.
Well, the report is, uh, you know, seven categories of evidence, right?
Mm-hmm.
Um, Immaculate Constellation is the attention grabber, but it's the one where there's the least amount of, uh, detail.
Right.
Um, so I basically conducted.
I did my own, uh, amateur all-source analysis, uh, of what the US government, specifically the DOD, because that's what I had access to, uh, knew about UAPs.
And I collected that information and, uh, sought out a way to go to Congress because they asked and provided amnesty for whistleblowers.
If they did not want that, they should not have written that into a law.
Right.
They said they did.
And you started to go down that path.
And that's our kind of next step is your secret.
Seeking whistleblower protection.
Okay.
So now you realize you got to do something and you feel compelled.
I think we understand why he feels compelled.
It's dangerous.
Um, you seek whistleblower protection officially.
Is that the next step or what's the next step?
The next step is to figure out how to even get to Congress.
Okay.
Um, and actually a little bit before that to figure out, like, am I even needed?
Um, because at this point, you know, the legislation was there, but Grush was not.
Mm-hmm.
Um, I was aware of people on the inside, some of whom have since become public.
Some of them have not, who, uh, the very least shared a interest in this getting a wider exposure in the intelligence community.
Mm-hmm.
Um, so I started talking to people in that world.
Um, and trying to quietly figure out, uh, you know, what's the state of play?
Um, is what I have valuable or needed?
Right.
Should I, do I need to go forward?
So there was a long feeling out period there.
Um, lots of mistakes made, but.
Those were mistakes born of risk because, uh, you know, this, this is, there's no channels for this.
There's no official process.
We're all uncharted territory.
And I'm literally in the belly of the beast.
Back to a constellation, you begin to get the sense that it is in fact a constellation with a lot of individual stars or, or stovepipes underneath it.
Could you describe that structure, what you learned and how you learned it?
So that just, that's just a more of a nature of, of, of SAPs apparently.
Right.
Um, learning and how they're constructed.
And especially how the internal security for SAPs is run.
Um, I think you guys have reported on it that the budget for security is much higher than the budget for the actual research on this.
Um, and that is a very, there's very real world effects as I came to learn.
Describe those for example, you're, you're telling us that you realize the guys you're working for are lying.
Yeah.
Um, do you start to feel marked because of your interest in this or do you make mistakes that, that put you in somebody's crosshairs?
Uh, so there was no indication that anything untoward was thought about me.
Um, no, as far as I knew, nobody even knew I was interested in this stuff.
You feel a sense of duty.
Congress needs to know, you know, they've been lied to specifically.
People tell you, yeah, this is an important piece to the puzzle and you felt a sense of patriotic duty to do that.
And so you took steps to that.
You said, cool, they're going to give me whistleblower protections.
I am a whistleblower.
What happened?
How did you do that?
What were the steps?
So.
I had to find them.
There was no way that I could find to get into contact with the Congress.
I tried.
So then I started talking to other people who were at that time, more vocal about their intent to be a whistleblower to Congress.
Internally more vocal on classified systems.
Yes.
Or in, uh, not so much on systems, but in classified facilities, verbal conversations, uh, so met one person.
Who did go forward, uh, kind of watched that person without letting them know what I knew to see, you know, what they were doing and how it went for them, uh, at that time, it just seemed to be the report was, you know, I went in, talked with staff, the staff, then had a separate meeting to talk with the member and, uh, there was no paperwork, no lawyers involved.
It's just, you're in, you say what you have to say and you're out.
That's the channel.
No repercussion.
That's what they said.
We know all of those people.
As well, the assumption, none of, there's not a, uh, SOP written out, you know, this is what I'm learning and what observing and you told them what you know.
Correct.
Um, officially, yeah.
The first meeting, I wouldn't say I was especially transparent, uh, going in.
Remember I knew it.
I knew my bosses were lying.
Um, I'm talking to a permanent member of the Senate staff, not a member on the elected representative.
I don't know what their could have been bait.
You would be careful.
What could have been bait.
So I shared, you know, the, the tension grabber, the ImCon story, uh, and slowly worked my way around those other categories of evidence, but left it at like, you know, I got more to say, but like, you know, we should probably, you know, do you want me to say more?
Like what comes next?
Um, so that meeting was had, I, uh, spoke to that person in the SCIF, in the heart Senate office building.
I signed my name on the log, my true name on the log book.
On August 17th, we've been into that SCIF majority that long as well.
So unless that page goes missing, it's there.
Yep.
Um, you got balls at church bells, man.
I mean, going in there and doing this uncharted territory, you just trying to do the right thing.
I can kind of feel it, you know, that that's a difficult thing and you did it and you went in.
Yeah.
What happened?
I don't know who to trust then either.
Right.
Uh, so what happens next is I'm told, okay, so we're going to set you up, uh, to be clear.
I.
I spoke to a staff member from SISI.
I was told that next you'll speak to a staff member from SASC, and then we will have a meeting with both SASC and SISI with the elected members of Congress there and the two people I, or sorry, and the staffers that is supposed to, that's what's, what's supposed to happen.
Right.
So I feel a little better leaving this meeting.
Actually, the person I interact with seemed very genuine, um, took my concerns for safety very seriously.
Um, and, uh,
it was perhaps oddly, but it was somewhat comforting, seemed to know more than me because at that point, um, I hadn't really meant anyone who at least willingly was going to answer questions and seemed like they knew, uh, even a degree of what I knew at the time.
So, yeah, I, I felt like, okay, we're on track.
There's a process here.
Congress actually is getting this under control.
Um, I'll have these meetings and it's, you know, uh, I get a handshake, maybe a nice little thank you.
And I feel like I did my duty and I can.
Get back to my career.
They're asking you to come forward and you do it.
So none of those meetings ever happen, uh, weeks go by or reach out.
Hey, is this going on?
Like I told you I had more, I want to give that more to you.
So I don't have it.
Um, when can we meet, got the runaround, uh, and then eventually the blunts reply, like you either send me what you have in writing here on this, uh, non official channel.
Or, uh, you know, you don't, and we don't need it.
So I, I sent that extra information and then for many months, uh, I thought, you know, I'm, I'm done.
It's disillusioning.
Isn't it?
That the Congress has made a show of this.
Hey, we want the information.
We're going to pass this legislation, protect whistleblowers, come on in, tell us this stuff.
And then the, the channels really don't work.
I came to be disillusioned at the time.
I just, uh, I came to believe like, okay.
I had something that was of minor importance.
I'm just really not important enough to talk to anymore.
So you're the little guy.
Shut up.
We don't need you anymore.
Also just the fear, right?
The fear that you're, you're trying to do the right thing.
The sensitive topic, you know, people are lying.
Who do you trust?
And all of a sudden you do what they say, there's gotta be fear.
They're like, oh shit.
Should I have opened my mouth?
Yeah.
But I think at that point though, it was mostly hurt.
I still thought like, I guess I'm too small, but too small.
And I guess you guys got this already when I talked to be clear.
David.
Grush.
Yeah.
Just spoken the month before or by before then I was clear.
Like, Hey, uh, you know, this meeting has been in the work for months.
I, I saw David Grush's testimony.
I don't even know if you need what I have anymore.
Right.
Um, this guy has seems to have it all, but yeah, they still wanted to talk.
Did there come a time then when you start meeting physically meeting with
other people who are sort of like whistleblowers or at least making
sounds like whistleblowers?
Yeah.
So that came about, uh, the person who connected me to Congress, uh,
started trying to make a network of people in the IC and the military, uh,
you know, for what ends, it was kind of vague, but it was more of a, at least a
community of interest, maybe looking towards like a group of current and
former national security employees that can, you know, be a resource to the
Congress can call on to either like, you know, speak or just to like make a
statement, you know, legit getting organized.
Yeah.
You gotta be thinking, well, look, I'm going to go hear from some other
people, see what their experience has been like.
Maybe I'm not doing this right.
And there's another way to do it.
Well, I mean, at that point I had accepted that, you know, they
didn't need my information.
I didn't feel like there was anything left to do.
Now I'm back at, well, I just want to know what's going on.
These are the people like me sort of, uh,
did you have to tell your bosses, Hey, I I'm under whistleblower protection.
Allegedly I went in whistle blue.
Did you have to like tell your bosses that your normal job?
No, I did not tell my bosses, uh, this point in time, I was at the
department of state when I was a whistleblower to be very clear.
Mm-hmm.
I was a whistleblower when I, sorry, I was at department of state employee
when I reached out to Congress and I was a department of state employee
when I spoke to Congress.
So I get a, another job, uh, with an FFR DC.
I was going to work at DA HQ doing nuclear force planning.
Pretty cool job.
Yeah.
And then last minute, um, a job posting goes up from the department
of state and I'm told about it.
I kind of knew some of the people at the state department program.
Uh, so that was a bit of a draw.
I was like, okay, if I feel like I need some protection, this could be a,
this could work out well in the longterm.
So at the time it was kind of self-interest there, where it was like,
yeah, if I need to, you know, cover my ass and write something, um, and
have it not be redacted, this is a good place to do it.
That's that's pre-planning, right?
The, and that comes from a, um, a sense of a worry, a sense of fear in a way.
And like you have to protect yourself.
State department's good place.
You're already thinking ahead.
You're not doing pre-plubs.
Book or being a movie you're doing pre-pub to protect your ass.
You got a new job at the state department.
You have in the back of your mind.
Look, if I decide to take it a step further, this is a good place to do that.
Right.
What's your job at state department.
And did you like it?
Yeah.
So my job was, uh, on paper, sort of similar to what I had done, uh, at the
Pentagon working in countering WMD.
It's a cool job.
Why was it cool?
So the state department, one of those, mainly the, the draw, I mean, is to travel,
um, and is to travel.
To, you know, countries that I wanted to in, in, in my case in Europe, um, you
know, the you're interacting with, uh, universities, industry groups, government
sort of associations, uh, much more slower speed, much less dark and grim.
And, uh, in the real world, as it were, was there ever a period where you're
thinking, maybe I'm just leaving this UAP stuff behind me and, and, um, oh, no.
No, no, uh, you were hooked, you were done.
You were well, I mean, the subject matter, obviously, and then knowing what I knew
about the situation in government, um, you know, I don't think it's something that, you
know, you have that level of, of knowledge that you can leave behind morally.
You couldn't.
Yeah.
Morally also is it's still to this day is endlessly fascinating.
Right.
But my job would have nothing to do with that.
And, uh, yeah, I, I.
I, uh, it felt like at this point, again, I had not gone to Congress, but I had
met the people who either were going to, or had felt like, you know, okay,
somebody's it's handled people seem more senior than me who have connections
and know what they're talking about or they got this, so I can rest easy.
Let it go.
Mm-hmm.
At what point did you read the transcripts of Sean Kirkpatrick speaking to the
senators was at, at the state department?
No, that was at USDI.
I'm just trying to figure out at what point you.
Decided, all right, you know, I tried to go to Congress.
Uh, obviously you knew that arrow wasn't the way to go.
So you had to make a decision at some point.
Oh, yeah.
I'm gonna take some action some way.
Yeah.
So the, the NDA language comes out, um, you know, I recognize how serious that
is, I'm talking with these people, even though now I'm at, uh, uh, states, I'm
still tracking what's going on.
Um, and start getting the, the, the scuttlebutt that, you know, somebody big is
going to come.
Um, and, you know, the implications of what they had to say are like, not good.
Uh, and they're making these people who are more senior than me, uh, feel or talk
about like, you know, that there's corruption involved, that there is a
conspiracy, criminal conspiracy involved, you know, nothing is being whispered, but
you know, things start to feel like, oh, maybe this isn't so, uh, just a cold war
black program that was allowed to go on for too long.
And now it's just coming in from the cold, all nice.
And.
Cute, like something much darker, right?
You see people like Dave crush, come forward and get slimed.
You know, that there are other whistleblowers who, uh, have come forward bits and pieces.
Uh, there's, you'd have to realize at some point there's a lot of risk in taking action.
Yeah.
I mean, I went forward in such close proximity to crush that I didn't have at that time.
I hadn't observed, uh, you know, the, the blowback, it looked like from the outside that, you know,
he, he had some friction on, on his way there, but it looked like he got to Congress was saying the right things and Congress was going to do something about it.
There was momentum and, you know, I, at, again, at that time I was already, uh, in talks to go talk to Congress.
Um, just at that point, not so much, uh, like, you know, out of fear and desperation, just as like, you know, they're asking for people, it seems like they need it.
Right.
Um, no matter how.
Small, it seems like it's important.
So, and this person told me it was important.
They ballot this person I met with, uh, I met with one-on-one.
I told them about this, uh, USAP, which at the time, you know, I still to myself, I was like, I don't know if it's real or not.
You say you've been to Congress and you know, these things firsthand, like, is this it said it was, uh, and yeah.
So how have the, those interactions that we've already been over, um, where do things start going for me?
Uh, uh, what's the phrase here or serious, um, is after Congress, uh, after, sorry, after speaking to Congress as a whistleblower, uh, I interacted with, I continue to interact with this person who was trying, or at least they told me they were trying to start a fund for whistleblowers to help get people out of the legacy program who wanted to speak, but couldn't because they're both afraid for their life and their livelihood.
And I thought, well, there's something I can help with.
Um, good at writing paper, um, you know, we'll, we'll make this organization and I can contribute there.
And so the, the, the honeymoon phase of, uh, you know, I, I did my, I spoke my piece and now it looks like I'm helping the good guys and things aren't that serious continues, um, after August of 2023.
Uh, the result of that is, uh, sorry, the result of crush and all that we get the UAP disclosure act, uh, or the attempt to do it.
And it's so.
Yeah.
I think when that failed, um, was the first blow to, uh, that hope that, you know, things would be handled constitutionally constitutionally.
Is there a point at which you, you see, let's call it the whistleblower community, a small group of fairly small group of people who have different stories that you become disillusioned with them and with the, their media contacts who are being fed bits and pieces of information.
Now, yes, then no.
Um, there also wasn't as much media penetration or connection, whatever you want to term it, uh, in those circles, at least that I was, you know, a part of.
In those days, did you consider going to a, uh, no, no, I had no outreach, no connections to media.
Uh, and I was not pursuing connections to media at all.
And, you know, to be fair, you're kind of navigating all of this stuff.
You're seeking advice from people trying to figure out what do I do?
and um and you're you're a smart guy and you you look at the world and you start reaching out to a
couple people or they're being introduced to you like myself and you're kind of feeling it out too
like you know what is the best path forward here yeah that's so sort of what happens next is um
the uapda fails and before that we get word it's going to fail right um and this person tells me
that congress needs people to start fires right to try to save the uapda i ask him are you are you
serious is congress has told you to ask people to make some noise yeah and try to save this thing
that person told me yes and so then i started trying to find uh some media personalities who
could potentially be trusted one of my next steps which was well now i got to get something cleared
but then
set
back in a different way which was well shit we still have all these people apparently who are
in danger there's no help from the government there's no help from congress there's no help
from um arrow arrow there's no help from people who say they care about humanity but their actions
don't bear that out so back to square one and for me square one is going back and re-engaging with
congress so i i reach out um in that yeah
i guess this would be winter of 24 23 around there back to my uh sissy uh connection and that
person i learned had since moved on and he connected me to the current uh person current
staff member for sissy who's handled this arranged a meeting in a few months because i told them hey
i'm gonna just first of all i asked like hey did you get any of my testimony the answer was no or
um at least that was the claimed answer
so i said uh well did you get any notes like i know he took notes did you get notes of what i
said nah so i okay you know what i'm gonna write this all up for you guys you have it and you can't
lose it and um you're gonna guarantee to me that this is not just gonna stay with sissy it is gonna
go to sask and it is gonna go to hask and it is gonna go to hipsey like it was promised before
but never did those acronyms meaning for the senate committees and the health committees that
would deal with these classified sensitive stuff you're like fuck this i'm writing it all down
writing down
really your problem right and you gave me amnesty right you want this i'm giving it to you right
so i spend uh some weeks uh laboriously typing this out um you know hidden drives on encrypted
drives using open source software only able only opening it when i know i'm not connected to
anything on a new device uh not a very fun drafting process right
um and that's just the technical aspects of trying to be secure about it at this point
and i'm definitely under no illusions that the u.s government some capacity knows about me
i'm mainly concerned about foreign intelligence um and their possibility of collecting on
on me i'm in dc spy capital of the world uh i i was very concerned about that and wanted to do
even the writing of this the correct way uh so during that time
draft this uh i observe what's going on uh continues to go on the the final death of uap uap
disclosure act one and the attempt to get the second one which is totally watered down and not
even worth our time to consider um and i go and i have the meeting with sissy uh give them the paper
um it's a much longer version of the report both in my analysis and i'm going to have to go to the
the level of detail additional detail in the evidentiary evidentiary sections
um including the various compartments and programs that they could themselves
uh look into to access the same information that i saw which is ridiculous that congress
has no access to um gave all that to them uh then really had to press to even get to
speak to sask eventually got to speak uh to sask uh
to the department staff at i believe the rayburn office building um then after i had met with both
sissy and sask i uh i uh or no after i met with sissy but before i finally met with sask i submitted
a version of this report to the state department because i uh after i gave it to them the first
time um they said thank you very much um and then never heard again didn't even i mean they're asking
for you they're asking for you to come and they're asking for this and you're so i decided to kick
open doors exactly please take this exactly uh so i decided to make myself a little dangerous
and said hey i'm going to submit this for pre-pub review um to and i'm going to brief my leadership
at state department on this which i did and i then after briefing them i submitted it to pre-pub
review and uh that's to take that the state department met with sask provided a copy of
the full report and at that time the cleared one um before that ever reached any media sources so
that they knew what the media would see before anyone else you know doing what i thought was
only fair you know you want you're our leaders you want uh control you want this to go the right
way i'm giving you full insight into what my words are you can tell me at any time to stop
or what to change in my words nothing transparent but also you ain't fucking around anymore right
yeah no pushback at all none except for uh not after the sask meeting never getting access to
house at that time you make this and no access to members still and that's where we start a process
but right so you you make the submission you get an answer back up what's it say uh you know i get
no redactions requested and essentially a one word sorry one sentence answer uh you may proceed
not exactly
something that gives you a lot of confidence at all as well but i mean it sounds like they're
saying go ahead we have no problem with it yeah um i mean we have the emails you can read between
the lines and also the tone um certainly nobody there was thrilled about what i was doing right
but they weren't stopping you and um you know a lot of people hear about dopser and that kind of
thing and uh this is a very interesting way to go about it you you get pre-pubbed through state
department which later sean kirkpatrick became public made some disparaging comments about what
gets passed
through when it comes to going through state department doesn't matter basically it's a
process for you to cover your ass and inform everybody and and say i'm not messing around
here we go and and you get you get it all written out you get approved and one sentence
you know email back that we've seen and and you don't have high level of confidence right of like
well what does that mean can i move forward so there you are what happens next i fly out to
california and i meet with michael schellenberg
in part three of our interview with the author of the immaculate constellation report what is it
like to have um absolute knowledge that not only ufos are are real that we've been hiding that
that our government has controlled that information away from human the base human
population what i have learned is that we live in a dream a carefully constructed reality
we make use of a science that is tightly controlled and suppressed and distorted
who are they why are they here why don't they show us what's going on i think i have a good
degree of confidence that the reason they're here is us i think life especially sentient life
it's a precious thing and i think to some it might be a resource